hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is
joe desenna joe is the founder of
spartan the whole spartan race series
this is an incredible conversation i
think it's
designed to really inspire how you think
about the new year
and get you off on the right trajectory
as we think about 2021
so without further ado hit that
subscribe button and please enjoy my
conversation
with joe desenna
[Music]
right on man so good to see you we've
been trying to make this happen for so
long
it's taking forever man i don't know how
many got to be three or four years a
couple years i think the last time i saw
you
i did your show when you guys were
hosting an event at dodger stadium
yeah i think i like the last minute hey
rich can you come over to the stadium
and
we caught you we did some foot we did
some filming and we knocked out a
podcast right we did a podcast and then
i did a little
shooting with you for the documentary
with kel bustman what happened to that
documentary it's done
and um off the editing room floor
however you'd say it
and getting ready to be pushed out
what's it called
what the is your exit strategy and
the idea is
um and it probably pisses i know what
pisses you off
what are people thinking when they don't
eat healthy when they don't act healthy
and so like what like we talk about exit
strategy in business what's your exit
strategy from the planet
like do you plan on living in a hospital
for the last 20 years like
and and that title came about because
cal
a mutual friend of ours kal fussman
famous writer
uh invited me to breakfast with larry
king one day and so i'm sitting right
here and i mean
yeah i'm having a salad and
larry is pouring i mean pouring sugar
all over this bowl of cereal ah kid what
are you doing with the salad
and he goes i eat like this i got a
colonic every day and
and i just thought like what's the
exit strategy
and it came from there so is cal like
the protagonist is he the
he's who we're like taking this
adventure with yeah we took the
adventure with him
and he was impossible to deal with um
and
unbeknownst to me you know 20 years
earlier he did it maybe 30 years earlier
he did it with um
jacqueline and and i think cal is really
good
for an article or for film but then go
like most people falls off the wagon
when right when there's no reason to be
taking care of yourself
i just remember him being sort of
obstinate in the interview
like pushing back and it's like come on
man what do you what do you know
get on board here i listen i fought my
in-laws when i met my wife
my mother by the way my mother in the
70s was into yoga meditation all the
stuff that you're into
and she fought the whole world and so
there were no whole foods or yoga
journals back
then so i watched uh the pushback and
and it's i mean it's pretty maybe not in
california but the pushback is massive
everywhere to this idea of just take
care of yourself
yeah i mean look at look at um kovid
in the u.s versus everywhere else hmm
yeah i wanted to ask you
i mean it's got to be brutal right now
for you with spartans
how are you keeping this thing from
capsizing
you know when it first happened i became
friends uh last uh two years ago skiing
with the owner of saks fifth avenue he
owns a hudson bay company which is the
equivalent of saks in canada
saks fifth avenue incredibly successful
guy
and when it was all going down i was
with gerard butler check this out i was
with gerard butler i was in sparta
greece for the 2500 year anniversary of
thermopylae
the movie was based on the battle at
democracy
and trump closes the border and at that
moment it became very real
because because up until then we had
closed a few races in china i closed a
few raised in japan but it was like no
big deal this thing would be over
in a jiffy and i'm in sparta
and the country gets shut down and i
call my friend from
saks and i'm like what the and he
says um
he goes you gotta preserve cash you
gotta preserve cash you gotta protect
you know the employees that you you can
and you gotta stay in touch with your
customers
um and thank god i had that phone call
on march 13th 14th because um
because i would have just like i mean we
had 501 people working for us i got
325 events shut down overnight around
the world
and you can't keep paying people and
bills and all these things and
and lawyers and you know better anybody
the lawyers and and um
and not have revenue coming in so um
you know i'm ashamed to say i thought
i didn't listen to the advice of him i
didn't listen to the advice of my
friends that run hedge funds
i thought come july 1 we're back right
the world is back well we've never seen
anything like this in our lifetimes
there was no reason to think that we
wouldn't be able to get over the hump
and get back to some level of normal
and i'm an optimist i mean our whole
business is based on optimism right
and and i just thought yeah well here we
are
so did you have to lay off a bunch of
people 350 people followed
um and and uh i think we just did a few
more
um silver lining and all this is we
became a lot more efficient as an
organization
there were a lot of deficits in our
company that we never tended to
technology crm uh uh ecom
go down the lit things that we just
didn't have time for put on 325 events
and so we're becoming much better in
those areas but it's really a race
against the clock
it's um you know if we're back on next
year and we're allowed to put on events
it's going to be great yeah um but but
i just don't know i mean china we just
we uh two weeks ago
had 10 000 kids at a chinese event in
china
china is back in business they got
vaccines they cost 30
usd you and i could go up to the corner
store and get a shot in our arm
um but outside of that yeah
so you can ramp up in china i could ramp
up in china but
but the u.s was 50 of our business
um europe was 25 of our business right
go
so china does not offset but it gives us
hope that if china's back and they were
three or four months before us and
shutting down maybe three or four months
from now we'll be back
yeah we'll see we'll see who knows who
knows crazy
i know crazy so crazy well what i've
noticed in you
just from a distance is this
kind of pivot into really a media
company like
a content platform like suddenly you're
vlogging all the time and all you know
your video suddenly there's videos from
you like every single day
i know i've done i've gone a little nuts
i apologize for that
we locked down on the farm in vermont
yeah that's where this whole thing was
started my wife and i
uh had our four children i don't know
how to say that right politically
correct we she birthed
four kids on the farm i think you're
allowed to say that yeah
in in vermont along with cows and
chickens and goats
and um that's where spartan was started
as soon as i got back from
the thermopylae uh thing i just
described in sport of grease
landed on the farm holed up with an
olympic
wrestler that's another whole story um
a video team uh a bunch of people on
on the spartan team trainers and so
forth uh 12
13 of us and we just started filming
every day because there's nothing else
to do
right i like preserve your cash
protect your employees and stay in touch
with your customers so just film film
film film film because
i like to work and we couldn't put on
events and so that's yeah and you keep
the brand strong
and you keep people excited about what
spartan
is and they hear it from you directly
yeah so just
lots of um filming but as you know it it
drains your energy levels because you
like right before we just started this
podcast anybody listening or watching
rich and i were talking regularly as
soon as the filming started
you perked up your chest came out yeah
and you were like i'm trying to be
normal man i i want this to be as
relaxed no but we both did it yeah you
don't even notice you're doing it right
so yeah
it just sucks energy out of you well i
just noticed like this
is i think this is the fifth podcast
i've done in the last seven days we're
on a bit of a tear
and it's draining man like i you know i
don't know like how rogan does
you know four or five of these things a
week maybe it's because he doesn't
prepare but like i
i prepare like i put a lot of energy
into it i want it to be this amazing
experience and when it's done
it's kind of like an athletic event then
i i go home and i crash
and now like yeah it's like it is its
own kind of endurance thing and it does
take
even though it's not physical there's an
emotional like energy toll that it takes
it'd be easier i think you'd agree with
this it would be easier to go for a run
oh for sure right yeah and and your mind
is working but your body you're
breathing
you're sweating and this is also i can
control that you know with this it's
sort of like you
there's an aspect of trying to you know
have guardrails up and direct it in a
certain
way but at the same time you have to
like let go and allow it to be what it
wants to be so there's a vulnerability
with that that's different from
going out and pushing yourself where
it's just you and you no doubt
yeah and so and so i just went through
you know let's call it 120 days straight
of filming on the farm every day and um
something cool happened this weekend you
might not know about is once we realize
hey this is going to go on longer than
we thought there's going to be much more
painful than we thought we got to lay
off more people
i said you know we need an event we need
we need one event something to show
our community seven million people that
like we're still here
and and shit's still happening so this
past weekend we brought uh 12 women 12
men
from crossfit from triathlon from the
nfl
spartan and um we brought them all
together to find out who's the fittest
of them all
and we held a and my team came up with
the whole thing i can't even tell you
all the names of the athletes that were
there because they re
my team organized i just wanted to have
a spartan event and they came up with
this whole thing
and they actually actually wouldn't
allow me back on my own farm because i
needed another covet test
so here i was outside my own farm while
this was going down
but um we had a highland games type
event we had an ultra run
we had a triathlon swim we had a
mountain bike
we had a deca event which is our uh
almost gym
product if you would a combination of
the airdrying bike and the rowing
machine and
and all that we had a race to the top of
the mountain and we had a spartan race
and i don't want to give anything away
but um
you would think you would think that the
specialists
in each one of those areas would win
their area
and i'll just leave you with this they
didn't yeah that's interesting yeah
that's fascinating i would suspect
that the person that comes out on top
has a lot more to do with their mental
fortitude than their physical
prowess or their athletic gifts it's so
funny to say that because i was
i was thinking and you correct me if i
don't have this right but i thought
all right let's let's measure let's
let's set some um
what are the items we're going to
measure strength uh speed
um endurance athleticism um
and then i said wait but you got to also
measure resiliency and grit
yeah right because because some of this
is going to require resiliency and grit
and when you look at without me giving
it away who the winners were who the
they were the ones with the resilience
yeah uh-huh yeah hundred percent right
because i don't know how long this thing
is yeah okay so that's gonna separate
the wheat from the chaff
right that's like a reality show it it
was so
like battery the network starts freaking
unbelievable yeah well just it's just so
unbelievable you can't even imagine what
went down
it's it's a show yeah that's cool um
well i want to take it back your
your backstory is so epic i mean it's
cinematic it's like its own
movie it's just a crazy story
it's a crazy story
you're quietly like such a beast in
terms of like the
endurance stuff that you've done like
it's insane i feel like that gets
overlooked but
let's go back to the beginning back to
queens
so if anybody's i've seen the movie uh
goodfellas
out there raise your hand most people
have seen it right
ground zero for that movie was the block
i grew up on
um i'm trying to remember the exact
address but 84th street 149th avenue
in lindenwood queens or howard beach
queens jamaica
and um for whatever reason a bunch of
wise guys located on this particular
block
and and their game their profession was
was stealing from kennedy airport and
that's what's portrayed
that's exactly what's in the movie
that's what's exactly what's in the
movie and so
there wasn't a morning that went by
where i didn't wake up
with my sister and we'd go down into the
garage and there was a new
big box on a pallet of things there
like it could be leather ski gloves 500
pairs
uh it could be adidas um superstar
sneakers just
heisting the cargo trucks that are
coming in and out yeah and so it was
very common to go shopping
we were young my sister and i at this
point my friends but you'd go shopping
in someone's house
it wasn't like you'd have to go to a
store you went to someone's house and
there was all kind of
but you don't know as a kid what this
means anyway
we grew up in this in this crazy
neighborhood um
my parents are getting along
everything's fine your dad part of that
or just the neighbors
so the way i'll answer it is um my dad
had a trucking business
in in the airport eventually a a fairly
large
uh warehouse and airfray business and
it was hard it was hard to be in that
business
unless you couldn't be in that business
unless you have some relationship
yeah some relationship right yeah but i
will say my dad
no bs my dad was amazing in that his
thing was
if you go in that direction you waste so
much energy and so much time like and
you can't spend the money because it's
not legal
like you'd be better off putting all
that time and energy into a legitimate
way
a legitimate life but but i'll say that
like if you grow up there and you come
from that place and you're in that bit
it's pretty hard
to not be in it it was nobody
not in it right in that neighborhood
right so
so um and i'll and i'll i can't go
deeper than that but
but um i got it you got it yeah so so um
and there's very few people left um so
anyway my parents are getting along my
dad
uh starts making some real money and we
move 15 blocks
uh uh south of of where we were
which is a a better area and our
neighbor is the head of the banana
organized crime family 15 blocks up
and around the corner is is is the big
boss um
of the gambinos and there's four of the
five family heads
are living just around us in this area
15 blocks
south of where i where i first grew up
and my mom goes into
uh her mom dies of cancer my mom goes
into a health food store to just explore
like
is there another way to live rather than
you know granolas and raviolis and pizza
and
she just didn't feel healthy and she
lost her she watched her mom just die
she walks into a health food store she's
probably the only health food store on
the entire east coast
at this point and there's a yogi like an
85 year old yogi that just landed at
kennedy airport probably from india
in the store and she starts talking to
him and somehow he convinces her that
she's got it all wrong and she's got to
become vegan
she's got to start meditating and she's
got to take up yoga and how to breathe
and cold showers all the stuff we talk
about now
and she comes home and she throws out
the sausage and peppers and like
literally transforms the house
which ultimately leads to divorce your
dad's losing his with those
everybody we were as kids because if
you're listening to this this sounds
somewhat nor that it was not it was not
at all she might as well just landed
from mars
right that's how crazy the stuff was
that she was preaching
and so they get divorced and she
moves us back um north to that 15 blocks
right so my sister and i are down there
for about a year my dad's
at the other house and then she's just
not fitting in
nobody's getting this thing that she's
preaching
and she moves to ithaca new york because
that was like where hippies were and
they were educated but she's going
moosewood
she's going moosewood exactly it was
that was a big part of our life yeah
and and um i'm kicking and screaming my
sister's kicking and screaming we don't
want to leave our friends in the
neighborhood any any kid
would feel this way and i'm attracted as
a young boy i'm attracted just like all
the other boys in town are
to the the guys with cadillac's the guys
with suits on the guys what rolls 100
bills in there but like we kind of know
what they're doing who doesn't want to
be that
right and what is the difference between
the wise guys you see in the movies
whether it's goodfellas or the sopranos
versus like your
real life experience with these guys
there's really there's really no
difference i mean from my perspective
of that age no one's ever asked me that
um
they were a lot more quiet
in the in the in real life um but a film
has to give you the behind the scenes
and so i didn't
you know what i mean i was they were a
lot more quiet they didn't have to say
much they earned respect you kind of
you just didn't mess around right like
you would imagine
um but very much the same
and they the in the godfather and
goodfellas and a bronx tale you could
like they did a really good job mm-hmm
if you're like
they really captured the the mannerisms
um sopranos not as much i did
i didn't feel it in the sopranos but um
but in those other movies
and the thing that you get is this idea
that
that even though they're outlaws they
still have you know these rules in this
code that they live by
and you know there's certain aspects of
that ethic
that are laudable right it's not all bad
right and so as a young kid who's
impressionable you see the bling but you
also see
there's a value system there that you
can kind of hang your hat on
definitely hang your hat on it um things
got taken
like everybody runs into a problem in
life uh-huh everybody runs into a
problem and so here
if you're sick community's taking care
of it each other like i remember running
to to the boss next door as i got older
and
let me go backwards mom moves to ithaca
um
my name my dad falls on on hard times
the 87
market crash hits all the things he's
working on are starting to fall apart a
bit
and the neighbor sees this and he says
you know and i'm probably 12 years old
and he says come over and clean my pool
saturday
so um that's a big deal you know getting
tapped on the shoulder and
boss wants me to come over and clean the
pool so i go over and clean the pool and
and uh he
sits me down and he gives me three
lessons that day and he says um
look if you're going to be here 8 a.m
you show up 7 45. on time is late
mm-hmm you think i'm at school about
stanford right right yeah
he says i'm getting an mba yeah if if
you're going to clean the pool i want
you to clean uh the lawn furniture the
shed
the windows whatever it takes make
yourself invaluable
all right that seems fair and three
never ask for money you'll get paid if
you do a good job don't have your hand
out
and unbeknownst to me at that moment in
time he's grooming he's seeing
here's a hardworking young kid right
right and
then he gives me another customer you
know two houses over
who happens to be connected to him and
then i got another boss's house and
before you know it i've got uh 700
customers
right um i pay for my own college how
how old are you at this point well i
started at 12
uh by the time i graduate college i'm 20
700 customers it's a it's a
multi-million dollar business at that
point and
it's all these guys it's all i could
walk in anybody's house and so i'm
feeling
this is great right like everybody
trusts me you're taking care of
i'm taking care of you get in trouble so
that was my point so
so my dad is telling me and he's right
stay away
from that life um but you find yourself
even if you even if you um
push back on that life make fun of that
let's say that's ridiculous those guys
are terrible
you find yourself in a situation where
like somebody owes you money
or you did whatever it may be and then
all of a sudden it comes okay to ring
their bell
uh-huh right and say hey i i need a
favor right and then you're in it
right once once they do that favor for
you they're right that's
and technically because he got me in the
business like
i mean i couldn't say no to anything
right right but once you
did you call upon those guys to do some
favors for you and then did you find it
difficult to then extricate yourself
from the whole thing
well so so yes i
i asked for favors often because people
owed me money uh-huh and
and um i remember saying to joe once a
guy with me 60 000
and he said um bring this bottle of
champagne
over to his house and just let him know
it came from me
and so i i go over to the house i don't
ask for the money i just say hey
joe joe asked me to drop this off for
you and he literally goes over to the
wall takes a painting down opens it safe
like in a movie grabbed sixty thousand
in cash and hands it tonight
there wasn't even we didn't even i
didn't even add was right it was
and and there were a few incidences
like that now now to the second part of
the question did you find yourself
beholden
i guess i got lucky in the sense that
giuliani uh came to be
and then one by one all these guys they
all started to go to jail
and and so i i didn't i didn't have a
long talent right like that was good
right right right i didn't know it at
the time so where does cornell come into
the whole thing
so kind of in the middle of the pool
business right yeah so i'm running this
business
i'm feeling great it's growing i buy a
backhoe
and a bobcat and i got a building and
and like
like it's a real business yeah right my
mom's living in another go so i have to
spend
a lot of time in ethical that's where i
live and i'm going back and forth
running the business by my dad's house
going back to mom
and i'm leaving high school in ithaca
going back to run my business no
intention to go in college i didn't have
like most families where they bring you
on a college tour there was no dis
even though i lived in ithaca where
cornell's look no one told me anything
about
school and my grades weren't that good
and my friend
says to me hey why don't we go to uh
cornell
and i'm i'm two months from graduating
high school yeah and i said well how
would we go to cornell
and he said my dad's a professor he'll
get us in
and that made perfect sense to me
because i grew up in the neighborhood
where you'd have a guy
and he would get you into a restaurant
or whatever so this is like
yeah we got us in college yeah so um we
both get dressed up we do our interviews
we do everything we're supposed to do
it's going to be a shoe-in and neither
of us get accepted
and now now i was intrigued like oh we
have a guy
we can't get in and i you know now i'm
intrigued in this thing
and tell me i can't now i got to do it
now where does that come from
because that's that's just born and bred
into you probably a neighborhood thing
like
like when we let's go back to your
conversation about resiliency and grit
and those athletes
in this neighborhood these guys went to
jail
they got killed um and and that was just
part of the job right
and then if and then if you were running
a somewhat legal business you owned a
local pizza place
or a trucking company or whatever um
you hustled you were up at 5 00 a.m the
diesel trucks were running the pizza
place was second generation third
generation they were making people you
know i mean like
everybody just just hustled so um
probably comes from that it probably
comes from just seeing
this like you know that i'm going
to get this done
like there's no right there's no no
right right
right so you get the no we get the no
and
now i want to go and i'm debating going
back to run my business and my friend
says listen my dad just said
we can go extramural we could take three
classes each
when everybody else gets matriculated
into cornell we can take three classes
each they'll do five
we're not official but if we do well
they have to let us in
logical so i said okay you know what
we'll do then
i said when i go back to queens to run
my business this summer i'll go to st
john's it's in my route anyway and all
the pools i clean in the workplace i'll
stop in st
john's i'll take a couple of classes
i'll learn how to study and uh
and then and then when i'm going to
cornell if if we get in
i'll have gotten my five classes done i
won't be behind the other kids
my friend says to me that's ridiculous
if we're gonna if we're gonna hustle in
september at cornell why don't we go to
vegas all summer and party
right right and that was a divergence
right there and that was a real big
lesson for me
on like delaying gratification so he
heads to vegas i head to st
john's i run my business we both meet up
in september we do our three classes
we do very very well i get two a's and a
b and for me in an ivy league school two
ways i i never got too easy
ever and uh reapply
definitely getting in now they don't
accept us right and and
now i'm even more invested i i did my
classes at st
john's i just studied my ass off and
they didn't accept me
and the woman the admissions woman says
to me listen
we'd have everybody and and their
brother you know trying to get in here
if this was allowed you're gonna have to
go to another school and then
after three years at like ithaca college
or somewhere else and then apply
and i was like maybe you didn't hear me
i'm go you know i want to go here
right uh-huh so i'm gonna do it again
and she's got to let me in
and so he diverts my friend taps out
does he go back to vegas
he goes back to vegas he goes to unlv
and i
i go back um do another semester do well
reapply they don't accept me do another
semester i do well
don't accept me my fourth semester um
i'm broken
i finally uh hit my limit my business
this is this is your own death race
yeah it's my own death race and i'm just
feeling like my business is doing well i
got all these
like i don't need this right i don't
need the headache and i tell my mom
you know i'm gonna pack it in and she
was probably bragging for four semesters
her son was going to cornell even though
i technically was not
a cornell student and she says go meet
my uh yoga
she teaches yoga my mom at this point in
the living room and she said go meet my
yoga student
professor anita racine um
she might be able to help you i don't
know uh-huh and my mom was the last
person i would have asked like for a
connection
because she was crunchy and bohemian and
my dad would have had the contact so
anyway
out of respect to my mom i go meet
professor
anita racine she sits me down looks at
my grades
asked me a bunch of questions she says
you know i run a department
within one of the schools at cornell uh
textiles we study textiles and
there's 92 women in the department
there's no men um do you like textiles i
was like i love texas i don't even know
i don't even know what a textile was
right like i'm in and so
uh she finally accepts me in and i end
up spending the rest of my time
at cornell studying um textiles which if
i had to do it again
i would do because i could watch any
movie
from any era and tell you based on
hemlines
what what uh what time it you know when
it's amazing yeah when that happened
what years were
were you at cornell then i uh entered in
86 graduated 90.
uh-huh so you left right before i got
there because i went to law school
cornell oh okay yeah high school is
beautiful i was there 92 to 94.
nice so you were out there but you got
him legitimately you didn't need the
posting i was no well legitimately sort
of i was the
last person admitted to the law school
class off the waitlist
okay so i showed up like i didn't think
i was going to law school i got in at
the last minute i was living in new york
city
and packed a bag and tried to figure out
where ithaca was and showed up
and everybody had been studying all
summer and i was like what am i even
doing here because i'd already decided i
wasn't going to go and it was like a
very spontaneous decision but
and then you liked it when you arrived i
mean i liked being
i was getting out of control in new york
so i like being in a structured
environment and i like school and the
law school
it's kind of like the shining there
though because it's so cold
and you're all in this one building and
a lot of the 1l's live in a dorm that's
attached to the law school
so they never go outside so it gets a
little weird
and incestuous but i basically just
spent most of my time at ruloff's
base i i uh bar backed
at rule oh you did yeah i mean i was
there like four nights a week
i was gone by the time you got there but
i i think i made 16
a week right and that's tough when
you're making
money you know like mid six figures or
whatever you're making in the pool
business
exactly but it was it was good for me to
it was a way for me to mingle and meet
other people while i was i like to work
obviously you're hearing that in my
in my story um and rather than wasting
time just drinking
i i uh which is the way i looked at it i
was
i was around it while i was working and
getting paid so
i could have used you in my orbit back
then man i needed a little discipline at
the time
um cool so then you get you get out of
cornell but then it's back to the pool
business
so um first of all anybody listening
that doesn't know cornell
and correct me if i'm wrong wrong rich
but the law school to me feels most like
cambridge or harry potter
at least from the outside it has that
look yeah right um
so i'm about to graduate on time
which was unbelievable because i was so
far behind from those
uh four semesters and i take
professor ben daniel's class at the um
graduate management management school
mba program right you did a combined
them yeah like you get i didn't do the
combined
i clearly was not smart enough for this
whole thing but but i was allowed to
take a class there a lot of people took
the entrepreneurship
class at that school and as part of it
we all came up with a business plan and
we presented that business plan to a
panel of judges
and i won i won the the the the uh
five thousand dollar award that came
from the owners of ryu needy wines
um they were awarding uh every semester
five thousand dollars to the best idea
best
presentation and the judge one of the
judges was an italian
guy and uh being from the neighborhood
i'm from i clicked with him and and i
bought him a bottle of sambuca i brought
her over his house and we got to know
each
other i didn't buy the winning slot by
the way i just got to know him
and and um he said what are you doing
when you graduate
well first of all what was the idea that
allowed you to win so do you remember
at cornell and many colleges they had
champion
branded sweatshirts with the silk
letters sewn on the front
sure and they were 50 or 40 and i just
thought
the way those uh sweatshirts were made
were where
people would buy the champion
sweatshirts the stores at cornell or any
would buy the sweatshirts and then
they'd have a couple of seamstresses
because i was starting textiles
would sew those letters on and i just
thought i could make them in asia
i could make them for each school um i
would change
the uh wristbands i'd add a little bit
of lycra uh so they didn't blow out
because
everybody would roll up there you could
wear those things a couple times and
they were done
yeah they would blow out and and so i
had this idea for a better cut
sweatshirt that was cut and sewn
in asia labeled in asia and um they
liked the idea
so they gave me five thousand dollars to
do it it's amazing you didn't go into
becoming some huge garmento
i should have yeah i should have been
retrospect but but um
so he says to me what are you doing when
you graduate i say i'm going back to the
neighborhood i got this business
he says you're an idiot i said what do
you mean he said you have a work ethic i
can see it you can talk you should go to
wall street
and i didn't really know much about wall
street i just knew the 87 crash
and um i just decided that uh
you know i want to run my business got
it was becoming a really big name
uh back then and i was plugged into that
whole thing yeah
and he stayed in touch with me so i went
back to the neighborhood i
run my business kept building it up and
he stayed in touch with me he called me
this guy called me every month on the
month
have you sold your business yet have you
gone to wall street no al stop calling
me
every month for like 35 months wow
okay and um and finally he convinces me
he calls me one day and he says hey
i'm gonna give you a stock tip if you're
not gonna listen to me i'm gonna give
you a stock div and i never bought a
stock
before i was busy running my business
and he says um
i want you to buy this stock syntax so
it's probably
like 1993 94. i want you to buy this
stock syntax
again i don't have an account i don't
know anything about it
that day i'm going to pick up money from
a pharmacist
one of my customers is a pharmacist he
owns a pharmacy and
he must know about this pharmaceutical
syntax
ring his bell i'm going to pick up my
check and i said hey my buddy just told
me to buy this stock
syntax he goes i can't believe you're
bringing that up i said what do you mean
he says i was just
taking a shower i was thinking i'm going
to buy some today and he brings me in
the house and he hands me my check he
owes me a lot of money
and we had done more than it was like
140 grand or something like that right
yeah
because because then we were not just
doing swimming pools we were uh
rebuilding houses doing patio work et
cetera
and um he sits me down he calls up his
broker and he says hey you should you
should um
you should buy 10 000 shares of this
thing 14 share 140 grand
and i you know i'm a pretty he goes
you're single
if if you don't you know you're making a
lot of money right now if you if you
lose it it's no big deal when you're
married and you've got children
so anyway he talks me into it i buy ten
thousand shares next day the company
gets taken over
i made a hundred thousand dollars and i
was like i'm going to wall street
right this is a hell of a lot better
than cleaning swimming pools and having
to chase my money and bring
bottles of champagne together safe to
open and so anyway that was it i sold my
business to my employees they still run
it today they're multi-millionaires
they're great
guys and uh went to wall street wow and
had to take a
serious pay cut initially right big pay
cut i went down to uh 35 grand a year
and um and then thought i was a genius
and started training
trading stocks and and options and and
lost most of the money i had accumulated
up until then but then dug myself out
and figured it out and ended up building
a business and
started my own firm uh where we we uh
executed orders believe it or not for
the
the jp morgan morgan stanley's goldman
sachs uh bank america's they were our
customers
everybody says why why would the big
banks give business to a pool guy like
and um i just learned in the
neighborhood how to service customers
how to do a good job a better job than
whoever they were using the people
skills i had good people skills we
hustled if we had to take a loss on a
trade kind of like
clean the windows and clean the shed
even though you're only getting paid to
clean the pool yeah don't ask for money
if we had to lose money we lost money
just and then there was one
secret weapon i had which which nobody
had
my neighbor who ended up going to jail
had a table at a restaurant
in um in harlem called rayo's raos you
see the the
the sauce in a lot of stuff yeah i've
seen that it's from that restaurant it's
from that restaurant and
that restaurant only has uh 10 tables
it's been around since like the 20s you
can't get a table at rails
denzel washington's in there the head of
new york stock exchange is in there a
couple of wise guys
you cannot get a table at rios i had a
table
because my neighbor went to jail and
they and so
that definitely helped um my wall street
business right because i was able to
bring potential clients
to rails and that's yeah that's right so
how and so where does the
endurance impulse start to enter you got
this like guy in your building right
who's running stairs and like
are you just gaining weight and feeling
lazy or where does it begin
yeah well we'll go way back my mom
introduces me to
like she's running marathon she
introduced me to this transcendence run
in queens i don't know oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i had uh sanjay rawal on the
podcast who made a movie about it yeah
exactly yeah
we have a 3100 yeah we gave money to
that movie simply because
of that connection to my mom uh-huh so
anyway she introduces me to that race if
you're listening
it's thirteen is she a devotee of uh
that was one of her
gurus right yes another guru um
and so uh for those listening there's a
there's a race in queens new york uh
called the transcendence run it's it's
one mile loop 3100 times
takes 50 to 60 days to complete it
and uh about eight people every year
right right and
and so anyway she introduced me to that
probably iron man i'm seeing on tv uh
marathons
but you weren't an athlete in high
school not an athlete uh i
i bic i bmxed that is not considered an
athlete
by any means but i was a crazy person
on a bmx bike like i would i would buy
tens
of miles on this one and it's hard to do
that with one gear a little bike
so um that was the only that was the
only skill i had if you could even call
that a skill
so fast forward um when i was running
the business
i'm mixing cement i'm laying brick we
are
working physically every day so i've got
that kind of endurance and it feels good
um now i'm on wall street and i'm
sitting at a desk and we're doing two or
three dinners a night
and i'm getting heavy and i'm feeling
terrible
and i still don't want any part of yoga
or any of that crunchy stuff my mom
talked about
but one day the elevator's broken in the
building
and i got to go up to the 30-something
floor and so i'm taking the stairs
and i'm huffing and puffing and there's
a guy as fit as uh rich roll sitting
here right
not nearly as fit as you get out of here
rich is ripped
and and and he's carrying two dumbbells
and he's going up the stairs
and his name's mike if i remember
correctly and we're talking in the
stairwell
and i'm intrigued this guy's like he's
literally a cover of men's health type
guy
right and he's got a shirt off and and
we got time to talk because we're going
up all these stairs and he's carrying
the dumbbells and i'm i'm more out of
breath than he is
and he says meet me in the stairs every
day we'll start training
and so that was the beginning i started
training in the stairs he introduced me
to an adventure race i had never heard
of an adventure race
which was a three-hour race where we
kayaked we biked
kayak biked and ran loved it
felt like i was mixing cement again and
laying bricks and doing construction
work and i was just like
went nuts right went nuts like
where's the next one where's the harder
one give me the hardest race in the
world and i just chased races for
and it was my way of eliminating some of
the stress i had on the trading desk
insanity
and so i don't i don't know from like 98
97 98 to like 2005
i just went nuts i mean you were on this
ridiculous
tear where you were flying somewhere
every weekend to do something
bananas there couldn't have been that
much training during the week in between
with the work schedule
that you're holding down so the training
and the racing become
one thing but i mean in that period of
time
i mean it's i don't know if there's
anybody else on the planet who
participated in more insane races i went
absolutely nuts and and
and i call it the spartan paradox and
maybe you found this as well
that the trainings like you got to
embrace the training right it's the
journey that matters but like
training sucks like the actual race is
kind of cool right and
and i found that as long as i had a date
on the counter i always had
i never fell out of shape right kind of
like you know a boxer gets a date on the
calendar he knows he's got to fight just
accountable
yeah and so i just clocked selfishly i
was like if i just
keep racing i'll just always be in shape
right i just never i never have to train
but you took it to
such an insane level i mean there's that
one there was like a one
like four day five day period you did
the vermont 100
100 mile run then you get on a plane and
you fly to
vegas and drive to bad water and you do
bad water for
in bad waters of race we talk about all
the time on the podcast
then you go to a wedding and then you go
to lake placid and do the iron man
and then what like four days you did
your research yeah five days or
something like that hardest part of that
whole week
was the wedding my feet did not fit in
the shoes how do you go from
running the vermont 100 to running bad
water i mean the hardest
i mean i i paced dean carnazzes at that
race and it just it almost killed me
just trying to support that guy yeah it
was hot it was 137 degrees the day we
did it
it was hot my shoes melted my shirt
melted i don't know i
i you know there's something amazing
about the human body the body gets more
efficient
uh-huh you would think like everybody
talks to me about well you got to
recover or whatever
and i don't know if if this was the
1700s 1800s you and i would not like
we wouldn't stop on a mountain with our
horse and carriage and say it's recovery
day today
you know you just keep going and the
human body just gets stronger or it dies
and so i just found for me
just get stronger like like my fastest
time
that hundred mile run in vermont fly to
vegas go to bad water
my fastest time in that 235 miles
was the last 13 miles of up to mount
whitney like that
i was flying so so that climb is brutal
i ran that whole thing like a lunatic i
probably passed eight people
and just because your body gets more
efficient
i'm not a special athlete all i did was
bmx as a kid i didn't what the hell am i
you know
so um the best part is how you finished
the marathon in lake placid though
yeah yeah well what happened was um i'm
feeling great in the swim
we got you know get there i sit in
iceland are you feeling great
i'm feeling great in the swim right cold
water
and uh i'm crushing i get on the bike
i'm feeling pretty damn good on the bike
and i'm like you know what this is gonna
be great
and within three or four miles on the
run i was dead
i was smoked and and uh i asked a couple
of kids i said hey
on the side do you have any aspirin
advil
they said no we got beer and i don't
drink
give me a beer and i drank one beer two
beer so i
basically got drunk i was eating
hamburgers i right i couldn't consume
enough doing that during that marathon
yeah
but you got that done man that is so
impressive
and then you've gone on you did furnace
creek you did this crazy
like 350 mile thing in quebec
i biked from vermont to the furnace
creek start line get out yeah
that was a 14-day bike ride oh my god
that was your training that was my
training for that yeah
yeah yeah i went nuts i went nuts i
whatever whatever it was a year where
you did 50 ultras and 14
ironmans that's got to be a record i was
in a what happened the reason that
happened is i was in a bad car accident
and um i was thrown out the window at 85
miles an hour my leg was ripped out of
my hip
so um i'm laying in bed and the doctor's
saying you're not going to
be able to walk again you're you know
crutches a wheelchair
and i just kept going to different
doctors till i got a doctor that said
you'd be fine
and um lisa smith i don't know if you
know her
she had gotten me into some of this
stuff so she called
to say how you know how are you i heard
you got in a car accident
i said look it doesn't look like i'll be
doing these adventure races anymore or
whatever she said why don't we do iron
mans
and i maybe i had done one iron man at
that point
and or maybe two and and she said well
just do every iron man there is
he's like all right let's do it yeah
because i was i was you know just out of
the hospital
right my leg had been ripped out of my
hip and a lot of times when you're hurt
though you see those athletes come back
stronger right so
it just gave me something to look
forward to and i just i went nuts that
year
it ended that year ended because my wife
was uh eight and a half months pregnant
with our first child i was at an ironman
i had just like
barely came in walking on the marathon i
was just
exhausted as you can imagine doing all
those things and she said are we going
to have a family or are you just going
to keep doing races
yeah i mean at some point you know it's
like what are you running from
you know you a lot of this is so uh
nourishing because it's it's connecting
you with yourself
and your potential and there's so much
to be learned about you know
you know what we're capable of right but
you can also hide behind it like you can
run from your life
by just being in too many events all the
time i i was um
i had never been married before so i
didn't you know i'm right
i was learning navigating that but for
me
although you might have better insight
into me listening to me for me it was
more about like
i was so stressed out in business that
whenever i got to a place where i was
like just wanting water food and shelter
it was so nice and i just liked getting
there
just like as long as i fall asleep in my
soup at dinner i'm happy
um does that make sense yeah of course
like that's what it's all about i mean
what do you think
like what is it that that what is that
experience for somebody who's never been
in that position before
teach you i guess for me
i needed to meet myself right i needed
to find out who i
am am i tough enough um
and i and i i liken it to if i had a
ferrari in the garage
and i just looked at it and i polished
it and you know
showed photos of it versus i took it out
on the track
and i raced it up against the you know
however you race a race car
you get to see how it handles and so i
was just i guess learning to see how
how do i handle right how do i do um
right and you get humble you get i i
don't know about you but i gained
integrity
during all those those crazy adventures
because um
i liken that to like a structural
engineer that
checks the integrity of the parts and
pieces before he puts the building
together like i was
i was testing the integrity of my parts
and pieces and
and i think when you've suffered like
that like you've suffered like i've
suffered
um it knocks the edges off yeah and it's
like you know when i meet
a really tough wrestler or a navy sealer
delta force operator and they've got a
somewhat soft handshake
they're that wave for that reason
they've been through some tough
they don't need to squeeze you does that
make sense or yeah i get that i mean i
think
when i think of you to like extend the
car analogy like your
rpms are running so hot all the time
because when you get back from that race
you're in wall street so you're burning
it in a different way
so there's no like recuperation
like it's amazing you didn't just
completely flame out yeah i had
i had zero recovery but
the other thing
the other thing is i mean i remember
flying to like you'd be able to look
this up
if my memory's off but i remember flying
once to like south africa
to knock out an iron man literally land
on a friday afternoon put my bike
together wake up in the morning
do the iron man at the finish line take
at the finish line take my bike apart
put in a box
and leave and then get back to new york
work
however many days i had in new york
three days and then fly back to like
western australia
it's like it's like crazy
what are people in the office thinking
well it cost me it cost me yeah right
because then the boss
if the boss can't be fully present i
wasn't president
but but that's the negative the negative
was i was showing my people that i
wasn't really interested right so that
was bad for business
but but what was good for business was
that became my brand
everybody else's brand on wall street
was like drinking and partying
my brand which didn't exist
you know at this time in the in the
early 2000s late 90s
was um i'm the adventure guy that takes
his customers to do yoga
right and on run nobody was doing that
yeah yeah yeah we climb
stairs for fun we don't we don't go
drinking yeah yeah
what's so unique about you and i'm sure
looking back you know
hindsight's 2020 but you're this weird
amalgam of
street hustler with this kind of blue
collar you know
aesthetic uh and also like the wall
street pedigree but you also have
the yoga hippie thing going on at the
same time and all of these things
fuse to create this unique individual
like nobody else could be you or do what
you do
without all of those elements like kind
of congealing
yeah and what i think about a lot is um
because we have four children now uh
from 14
down to eight years old how do you make
your there was a great saying in ancient
sparta like they need to be better than
us
our children need to be better than us
and so how do you make
how do i make my kids better than me and
they don't have the yoga crunchy mom
and the neighborhood and the wise guy
next door and you know they have a house
where it's so
organized uh for them that it's almost
like
it's a negative yeah you know so
that's the problem with you know
becoming successful
yeah it's like not good for the kids in
some ways yeah but you're running this
crazy boot camp up in
vermont with all these people yeah so i
mean the kids could carry rocks
right and the kids the kids could climb
ropes and they but
but they don't have a wise guy next door
that's right
you know little street wisdom yeah and
so i need i need to figure that out
they're learning latin
[Laughter]
how old are they now i've got a
eight-year-old girl uh 12 year old girl
a 13 year old boy 14 year old boy um
yeah i've got two daughters uh 16
and two older boys none of them are
interested in any of this stuff oh
really and i can't get them interested
and it's and that's fine like they don't
have i don't need them to be
but i find myself thinking like they'd
probably be better off but i don't want
to be the guy who's forcing
them to do something that they really
just are not wired to do
well so i forced it and i continue to
force it
every single day and my theory and we
will find out if i completely this
up
but my theory is they gain they hate it
they hate it they hate it
and then all of a sudden they score a
goal at a soccer game and they see
they're more fit than their peer
and then they hear from hey you're in
pretty good shape the coach said right
like
and then maybe it starts to stick it
clicks
and and i think i'm seeing that happen
but i might be seeing what i want to see
um so but i force it i force it every
day and i've been forcing it since my
oldest was four years
yeah yeah so well let's let's take it to
you so you basically at some point you
you know rip the parachute ripcord and
you're out of new york and you decide to
move to vermont and it's gonna be
retirement
yeah so i've got a picture of a red barn
on the trading desk
uh probably because in ithaca when i was
a kid
i saw some red barn in a field i mean i
think it's pretty ideal it's pretty nice
and that's what i'm visualizing the
country to be
and um i meet my wife and i'm like i
want to find
a place like that i wanna i don't wanna
be around the craziness i grew up in
i wanna get away from all these crazy
people on wall street and
and we're gonna find a farm and so we
find this farm
in vermont vermont was not in our plan
and the mistake i made
was i associated and this is like a jv
mistake
i associated country like ithaca was
country
with like but there's academics in
ithaca right there's
there's a university there you run into
professors like it's a little more
developed
that like anywhere in the country would
be like that but it's not
yeah and so we we found a farm in
pittsfield vermont a tiny little town
residents eight miles from killington
vermont the east coast largest ski
resort
and you know there's not a university
there
so there's a lot of negatives there's
some positives to not a big crowd you
know
but it's very hard to make a living
there and so we bought this farm
my wife was willing to move up uh we got
cows and chickens and goats and uh i
started putting on races i put trails on
the side and i mean we did
unbelievable stuff um but it's hard to
convince people even though it's only a
gas tank away from new york it's hard to
convince people yeah to come up to
vermont but it ultimately led
to me putting on a race we call the
death race right
right so let's talk about this because
this is crazy
and still exists right still exists and
what happened was i was in lake placid
iron man one year
i don't know when it was it was pouring
rain like like you read about i mean
crazy rain and for whatever reason i
think i had just gotten done with the
eco challenge
in in fiji where it rained like non-stop
i was at some race where it rained
non-stop for
10 days non-stop
and this is not gonna make sense i'm
gonna sound like i'm bullshitting but
like
i did that iron man it rained i didn't
even feel i did not even notice it was
raining i had just
left you know 12 days straight whatever
it was of rain
and i saw a bunch of top athletes men
and women quit that race
in the middle of it was that like 2008
or 2009
i remember there was one year where it
was just crazy it was craziness
it had to be before that because death
ray started before that so i said this
is ridiculous the name of the race is
iron man it doesn't say like
iron man except if it's raining right
right right right
and and i grew up with a mom who
meditated straight for 30 days like
this is ridiculous you'd quit because of
the rain
so i'm looking for ways to bring people
to pittsfield vermont anyway to our new
farm
and i'm like you know what we're going
to have this race called the death race
and it's going to emulate life and it's
going to
there's going to be no rules and and
it'd be like if you get out of the swim
in this race and you get to your bike
and the bike seat is missing
so what you got you got to do it on bike
seat
[Laughter]
that's going to be what this race is
right mm-hmm because that's what a ceo
would do that's what a startup would do
but they're they're the mindfuck goes
way further with this one
the mindfuck goes with yeah so first
year
we um doug lewis olympics downhill skier
shows up
the ashley brothers two guys from
vermont
i don't know any of these guys two guys
from vermont who eat barbed wire for
breakfast grew up on a
bad ass farm where the dad made them
chop wood for heat they're whole like
just
tough guys a teacher a female teacher
and uh a kid i convinced from wall
street to show up
about eight people just like the
transcendence run and
they don't know when it's gonna start
they don't know what it includes but
it's like
hand sawing through a log right
12 chunks so they're there for like
three hours hand sewing through this log
splitting that wood crawling through a
culvert a culvert is a hole under the
ground this was 120 feet long that water
rushes through um that they could barely
fit
in putting together a wheelbarrow with
japanese directions and no
tools but the thing is you don't tell
them when it starts
how long it's going to go for when it's
going to end or even what they're going
to be doing
and no idea right no idea what they were
getting into
and and the two rugged vermonters
and the olympic downhill skier are
battling for first
and the teacher is everybody else quit
the t
the female teacher who's in dead last by
like five hours
and we're trying to get her to quit
because i can't manage the front of the
pack
15 miles away from this woman in the
back and she says you you'd have to kill
me
like she literally just would not quit
uh-huh
so ultimately the skier wins and uh
the the brothers come in second and then
the female comes in uh
third after the two brothers and it just
the race just became this thing the new
york times picked up a story
and and they came and filmed it and and
the world got excited and then all of a
sudden 300 competitors every year would
descend
upon pittsfield vermont and the race got
tougher
and longer and crazier with every uh
year so every year you're throwing
something new at them right like it's
never the same
well you had like a didn't you have like
a bus where you would stand there and
say you can get on the bus and quit oh
you have no idea
so so what happened playing with them
what happened was the two brothers who
i've since become great friends with the
two brothers from that first race
they had done lots of big races
throughout their life they had
these are tough guys crazy races in in
the tundra like
they would have done really well in the
1700s and
they took on the persona of the death
race after doing it that first year they
started to make little skull
um necklaces they got tattooed like they
were just
into this and i started to see some of
the videos they were creating and they
were training
specifically for what we had just done
that first year
and i said i'm not gonna they're not
gonna do the same stuff the next year
i'm going to change everything
right and it broke them it drove them
crazy because they had just trained for
eight or nine months whatever it was to
do
exactly what i did they could put a
wheelbarrow together now you're trying
to figure out what their weaknesses are
so you can throw something at them
that's just going to derail their whole
plan
exactly yeah and so every year became
what are they expecting what are the
competitors expecting versus what are we
going to throw at them
it's it's diabolical it was diabolic
yeah
and and so you know they would roll into
town let's say on a thursday night
getting ready for
a friday afternoon start and they'd
check into the general store and they'd
have
khakis on and shoes and they'd be with
their family and i'd say race starts
right now
they haven't even signed a waiver yet
we're going right now grab an axe and
we're going
and um and so it just became this this
mystical
um thing that still goes on today right
and there was a
tv deal on the table at one point right
that didn't end up panning out yeah we
had uh
many many tv deals we've had so many tv
people uh
come up from the discovery channels the
nbc's and
invariably uh everybody gets really
nervous with that word you know death
race
um and it is it's a crazy race um yeah
people have come
really close to dying and so it um
how iron clad is that it's that wafer
we we make them in the waiver it says we
will bury you on the property so
we might not even tell them how is it
you know it doesn't get like a lot of
media though
you know you don't hear that much about
it you get a ton of media
um in like 2007 2008
but then from there spartan was born
right and spartan took over and then
tough mudder and spartan
to become a thing i mean spartan's
really born out of this idea
how do we take what's great about the
death race and make it accessible for
for the average weekend warrior and then
scale
and and formalize it and standardize it
like you're not going to find wood
chopping right right right right
right right right it was more
military-based like standardized for
spartan but
but that race is my baby and i love
torturing people
and um how many people show up these
days it's still about 300 people and how
many people finish
depends on the year what kind of mood
i'm i'm in um
i like how it's up to you it's really up
to me because because um
we could go till monday tuesday
wednesday and we could say all right we
only want three people finishing so
so imagine you're four days into this
just hypothetically which role is it
four days in
you can't see straight and there's still
12 competitors and i say to all 12 of
you i say
guys i i'm here we'll go as long as you
want right but until we're down to three
it doesn't end and people start dropping
right there right
it's like hunger games like you're
you're overlooking the whole thing going
how can i with these people
and improvise so easy to break people
and what have you learned about
the people that break last like what
does it go back to that grit
and the mental fortitude that is more
important than their physical
conditioning no doubt about it
the you could tell right away the big
muscular guys
they're out first they're out first and
it's it's it's a ceo it's a mom
that just waits everybody out you must
get navy seals and guys like that coming
in i lost the green bay out there once
literally we lost them we had search
dogs the whole thing we found them
in the attic of one of my barns sleeping
we had shut the whole race down looking
for a green beret we've had them all
we've had um every form of military um
you know the mma all of them have come
out to try to test themselves but
you know a lot of them quit in the first
three four hours
wow just like this is insane this guy's
nuts right
so spartan race begins i mean you're
you're up in vermont kind of
trying to be semi-retired and instead
you build this empire
yeah so so i'm done we're having
children
and this was gonna be like my time to uh
recover
we talked about recovery and death race
leads to this idea of spartan race
and 700 people show up to that first
event in vermont
and i happen to have discovery channel
there's a guy from discovery channel at
that first event
and he's seeing people across this it's
just a three-mile race
yeah and of course in the finish line
he's like oh my god are you seeing these
transformations that take place and
i'm not really paying attention to that
because i've got logistical problems any
race organizer you're dealing with other
stuff toilet paper
and he's like this is unbelievable
what's happening here
and that gives me the impetus all right
we're going to put on a second race
and a third race and a fourth race and
and then 1500 people showed up and then
3 000
and then tough mudder came onto the
scene and so then i'm a pretty
competitive guy then
right like that's like not getting into
cornell right i gotta bury these guys
and be the best i'm gonna win this thing
and so if they were
in the us and australia we're going to
slovakia
we're going to be i'm going to go to you
know i'm going to go anywhere they're
not and we're going to we're just going
to win this war
and really that battle between tough
mudder and spartan i think drove both of
us the founders
me and the founder of the mudder to to
really
uh build an industry they'll build a
sport out of this thing
yeah the difference from my perspective
is that with spartan
there's this you know elite aspect to it
where
you know you're you're able to tap into
a different caliber of athlete and that
allows
the weekend warriors to compete
alongside like these people that are
like
you know who become the amelia boones
and and the like
who became really celebrating yeah i
mean that was the difference
um the difference was they tough mudder
went out and branded it
it's not a race uh-huh right this is an
experience and we're actually gonna
we're actually gonna laugh in the face
of people wanting a medal at the finish
line we're gonna give him an orange
headband
like that was their shtick and our thing
was if i'm gonna do this i want to make
it a real sport
and honestly it was a business mistake
on my part because it was harder to
build what i was building it was easier
to build they were much more inclusive
like right a bunch of guys high-fiving
they could skip obstacles and they could
just earn a headband and drink a bunch
of beer i was asking people to like
train and work hard and if you didn't do
an obstacle you got to do 30 burpees who
the hell wants to do that
so so i was losing the battle for a long
time but because i'm such um
i just don't quit we ultimately won yeah
yeah we ultimately won
that is your super power just you're the
ever-ready battery this is never gonna
run out of energy
my team my spartan team says i'm very
much like um
a battery on your phone that's like just
out of juice but doesn't
die somehow like you're
you're always at six percent yeah
exactly and it just
doesn't die uh-huh that's funny the
other thing that's cool about what you
do is i mean it would be
normal for somebody like you who's so
focused on building spartan and all the
things that you're involved in
to just be focused on that but you've
really you really opened up your farm
and you have all these people that come
through it's like this open door policy
like hey you want to come here we got a
bunk house
stay as long as you like but you're
gonna have to do what i tell you to
so you're still doing this kind of
one-on-one
coaching and mentoring and there's been
some pretty extraordinary
success stories that have come out of
that yeah i do it
you know my wife hates it right because
i'm invited one i think i invited three
million people to the farm once but
people don't really you know it's a
little tom sawyer-ish right it's a
little uh karate kid
right whose name mr miyagi yeah right
like
you come here you paint the fence and do
this and that and people
don't really want to do it they might
not be happy with their life they want
to lose weight whatever it is they're
trying to clean up things
and they think they want to come but in
most cases when they get there
they tap out yeah there's a few
unbelievable success stories
the apples guy right the apples guy was
an amazing success story uh truck driver
uh 300 pounds uh he probably should have
been 160 pounds i got him down to 200
pounds in 30 days
uh he shows up with a little wheelie
suitcase he's like all right you know
where's you know where am i staying or
whatever i'm like
up there up where top of the mountain
the rafter oh it's tough
he takes the wheelie suitcase of
literally climbing up the mountain with
his name for like four or five hours
gets up there i got him in a stone cab
and he's like you know where's the
shower the kitchen
there are none uh-huh and a big bushel
of apples
all you're getting is apples we're
hiking every day lost 100 pounds
in 30 days obviously extreme obviously
easy to bounce back from that but like
that's the deal like like you can't they
can't do it on their own
and and so i provide that ability to do
a structured environment and strip
everything else away
take the phone away take the take the
food away
and yeah if they give me their keys and
they give me their wallet
we can get them to succeed at anything
they want to succeed at mm-hmm but as
soon as they have a plan b
or a way to escape um i can't help them
right so the recidivism rate you can't
control it i can't control yeah
i mean i had two guys show up uh two
months ago
big jacked guys during kovid i had a
bunch of kids come
family friends they sent all the kids i
put them through hell and
uh two guys wanted to come i said you
can come while the kids are here i'm
putting on a 14-day yeah no problem
and they spoke with like military lingo
they were not military guys and
they were gonna crush it three hours
kids stayed 14 days these guys made it
three hours wow
so what do you what's the differentiator
there they could leave
yeah they could leave i mean when you
when you can leave you you take that
option
and i learned that you know in this town
we didn't talk about
i rebuilt a general store that had been
around from the 1800s i rebuilt a farm
that had been around from the 1800s
and i envisioned finding some
entrepreneurs like i was back in the
neighborhood
to come run these things it'd be cool to
come run a general store right and
and you're not going to have to get a
mortgage and all that it's all paid for
it's all ready for you turn key just
walk in
and this farm has a tractor and cows all
you got to do is walk
you just got to do the work you're going
to crush it because you don't have the
strains that
any other entrepreneur has where you got
to borrow and you got to figure out ways
to make this work
i even have a place for you to live
they'll quit
and they quit because they're not
invested personally invested
yeah like when you write a check and you
sell your kids and do whatever you have
to do to make it you have no choice
and so that's that's the big difference
you know with the death race
they were all quitting and then one year
i said here's what we're going to do
if you want to do the death race you
have to get an article written in a
local newspaper that says you are doing
this race and you're going to finish
and all of it all of a sudden finishing
rates went up
it's that easy yeah yeah right that's
amazing
all these people that have come through
the farm
all the people that you've seen compete
in these spartan races
all the athletes that you've you know
run shoulder to shoulder with over the
course of these races
like what what are the what are the
lessons that you take away from all of
these experiences that
can inform the person who's at the you
know at the starting gate of a journey
like this
well so i'm a big subscriber in this
idea of fire ready aim
right just get started just take that
first step just go outside you know this
um i think we all get stuck sitting
around our brains are wired to avoid
discomfort
and so i find i find myself i know every
day i got to take my cold shower
and i find myself looking at my phone
and i'm like why the am i looking
at my oh i'm looking at my phone because
i don't want to get in the cold shower
subconsciously you know my my brain is
telling me to avoid that
pain i'm about to go deal with so just
take that first step
and that first step leads to another
step and before you know it you get it
done
and that might be signing up for
something that might be telling a friend
you're going to go
do something or maybe just having a
friend ring your bell in the morning or
having your
your shoes out next to your bed whatever
that is just take that first
step number two and i'm doing this a
long time so
i i think you have to have a frame of
reference
that you could you could fall back on
when the going gets tough so what do i
mean by that
like i always go to a place when they're
going and i say well it could be worse
like i could be in siberia i could be
missing an arm uh god forbid one of my
kids could be like
i i go through this place where it's
like it's not so
bad when i refer to some other thing
that could
be my reality mm-hmm and and i think
when you do that you have gratitude for
where you are versus resentment
and that's that's important to
understand right there's a lot of people
that resent
like oh i should have what he has or she
has or this or that
i never think that i think like thank
god
i have what i have because i don't have
what they have which is worse
yeah you know what i mean and is it the
result of all these experiences that
you've
like you know basically brought upon
yourself that allows you to tap into
gratitude in that way
no doubt about it if i didn't feel the
pain and suffering i wouldn't know how
bad like
as bad as it's been for me or you when
we've done these these
these races which are really just
manufactured adversity
we're still not like in the lewis and
clark expedition
pass not that bad yeah yeah right right
so
but you wouldn't know that if you grew
up on park avenue you pampered your
whole life
right you wouldn't so yeah so that's
probably why the mma fighter and the
navy seal
that's probably why their handshake is a
little softer and they're more humble
because they've seen hell mm-hmm but
with success
now you're flying around you're managing
this huge business
you're you're trying to direct all of
these races i know for myself
you know i'm i'm sitting at a table
having conversations with people
more than i am getting out after it like
as a result of of the things that we're
interested in we create
a certain large s in our lives that
actually makes it more difficult like i
found myself having to
exercise you know stronger boundaries
and
and challenge myself more to get out of
this comfort zone that i've created for
myself
do you feel i mean no doubt now you've
got kids and you can't go do 14 iron
man's in a year and all of that like do
you miss it and how do you
you know stay connected with that it has
to be
in discomfort i would i feel
i feel like it would be selfish of me uh
certainly for my family if i if i did my
you know go back to the old days and and
saturdays were my 12-hour day
if i did that on a saturday i stayed
away from my my kids
um that would be selfish and then the
other thing is i'm so fortunate i get
these
emails all day every day uh that you
wouldn't even believe
that like i'm back with my husband i'm
back on my wife i lost 200
pounds i left my job and started a
business because of sport you can't even
believe
the emails i get all day every day and
so yes
it'd be cool to go um hike a mountain or
do something but like
and i get asked by all my old friends
right we're going to climb uh
this or we're going to do that you want
no i can't yeah you can't do it i got a
family
right i got a business and we're doing
great work here so
i wake up early i wake up super early i
get my workout in i sweat every single
day
um i take the cold showers um
and and i run and you told rogan that
you bring a you have like a 44 pound uh
kettlebell that you travel with did you
bring it here is it here i did not bring
my kettlebell because
it's get the last three flights i don't
know if it's because of covid maybe
maybe there's less people working at the
airlines they're losing it
so i end up landing somewhere where they
get where some like you are expecting to
see it and i gotta run and go buy one
locally
quickly so i just didn't i didn't bring
it
um but and that stems from that
kettlebell stems from
one of the uh people that came to the
farm chris davis
was 696 pounds and he wanted to get down
to uh
in the 200s and i told him as you lose
weight i'll carry weight
and so uh he he got down the first
hundred pounds i i was carrying a
hundred pounds on a sandbag wow
and it was as you could imagine
difficult and
it's another whole story but i'm we
moved to asia as a family
right after that and so i had this
hundred pound sandbag that i was
carrying because i made that commitment
to him
and they confiscated it at the airport
so when i landed in japan
or singapore i said to my wife can you
order on amazon can you get a kettlebell
i don't need a hundred pound i'll carry
just to keep it going i'll count like a
20 pounder it came 20 kilograms
which was you know 44 pounds or whatever
so so um
that became my thing and and for the
last four or five years i've
pretty much carried it everywhere
outside of colvin uh-huh yeah that's got
to be a trip though when it comes
through on the baggage claim we're
trying to carry that thing on an
airplane
it almost took out yeah it almost took
out a um one of those security officers
once you know
coming down the ramp um in
india uh they stuck it in somebody
else's suitcase
once i checked it in i had to open
somebody else's
suitcase to get it out in in the middle
east they use a term to mean it's up to
god whether or not it'll be there when i
land
so it's been a it's been a trip carrying
this thing around and it's become a
shtick
yeah so how many people do spartan
pre-covet how many people recover so i
don't know if you know this right before
covid uh we purchased tough mudder we
bought tough mudder oh i didn't know
that
yeah so so pre-covered if you look at
spartan and tough mudder we're probably
1.6 1.7 million
people around the world um during covid
we're like 20 000. right yeah yeah
disaster but
but um but it's a big number 45
countries 325 events to the two two
companies combined
and yeah right and you have this mission
statement though
that you're going to impact 100 million
people our goal is to change 100 million
lives
gets us a free pass to heaven and um i'm
excited about that
so how do we scale this thing up i mean
you've got your books
you've got the podcast you got the
documentary you've got the races
i don't know what else you can do
to impact people at scale other than
what you're already doing
like at the same time when you canvass
what's going on
in america and across the developed
world we're dealing with
a health crisis of untold proportion you
know obesity rates are through the roof
childhood obesity rates are through the
roof diabetes
heart disease all of these lifestyle
illnesses that are just
felling millions of people unnecessarily
there's still
so many people that are suffering and
challenged to
find their way you know to a healthier
way of
of being yeah no i'm in the wrong
business for sure
uh all the data i don't think you're in
the wrong business well i'm in the right
business because it's something you and
i are passionate about right getting
people off the couch and doing these
things i'm in the wrong business and
that the data is going in the wrong
direction
um more and more people are eating
unhealthy more more people
are sitting and watching netflix
especially postcode but it's going to be
it's going to be even harder to get
people pride off the couch
so i would say if we could snap our
fingers sitting here and do anything
we would have to get to the white house
and convince them
uh or the pentagon and convince them
that they have to work with
us to mandate this kind of physical
activity
like it's the only way it's going to
work if if you want to get to 100
million people
because most people look at me and i'm
sure they look at you and say like why
why would i do that why would i do that
i mean like
netflix i could lay naked in bed like
garyvee talks about right and do nothing
so so it's a tough it's a very tough
sell
outside of the um let's call you and i
the hunter gatherers outside of the
remaining hunter-gatherer genes that
still exist
it's a tough sell yeah remember when we
were kids and there was the presidential
physical fitness yeah does that even
exist anymore
by the way of the dodo and it wasn't
that big of a deal but at least it was
something
you need that and now we have like lip
service to like corporate
wellness programs which you know i
question
how effective they are it's like getting
people excited about going out and
walking around for or standing up every
10 minutes or something like that like
how do you
have a soft enough touch that you can
get that person who's never experienced
anything hard to at least get interested
in it but not come at them
so hard like with your you know kind of
super hardcore sensibility
that they're intimidated and scared and
never do anything
it's tough when you that's why you need
you need programs that that it becomes
part of uh it's normal right when my mom
got into all this stuff it wasn't normal
so she
didn't get accepted and so we just need
to make it normal when
i've lived on the farm we moved to asia
we moved to
japan singapore when did you do that and
why did you do that
we did that because the business was
growing fast
i needed to beat tough mudder they
weren't in asia yet
and the kids were still young enough to
move so i said to my wife let's look
why don't we move we'll go asia light
we'll live in singapore first easy to do
uh we'll we'll land there we'll put
start putting on spartan
and then we'll expand from singapore and
what an amazing
experience as a family so but the reason
i bring it up
is because when i lived in those places
the neighbors
right around us started sending their
kids to me early in the morning to work
out with my kids so
i can do it if i have close proximity to
people i could rope them in
give them the olive branch lie to them a
little bit about you know
and get them to do more than they would
willingly do otherwise
but um you know when they're five
degrees separated
as you know it's hard to get them to do
stuff um look at the size of people
uh look at the data it's not going you
know they'd prefer twinkies over this
right so a uh
a cabinet position in the white house
for
physical fitness we just uh you can't
say whether you like trump or or biden
it doesn't really matter you can't
have a tagline that says let's make
america great again without
making america fit again you have to you
you agree like 100
it's logical anybody listening to this
we have to make america fit
and it only it has to be a policy driven
thing
my friend ran new york city schools uh
food program 1.1 billion dollar budget
he's just like you and i he did it
because he wanted he left goldman sachs
he did it because he really wanted to
make an impact he left
he says i got the potato lobby i got to
have the french fries
i got the soda lobby i gotta have the
soda he goes i finally
finally i convinced i i was able to get
wheat bread on the hamburgers
right he goes so i put wheat bread on
the hamburgers the bun
none of the kids will eat it so then i
gotta put a wheat
bottom with a white top to hide the
wheel yeah
so he just couldn't take it anymore well
you have to change the entire political
system to get
you know the lobbying you know efforts
out of there that keep
you know everything entrenched with the
shitty food because there's too much
money involved right now so it's
impossible for a guy like that to come
in
and make any changes i mean look at how
michelle obama just got shellacked
we're just saying maybe we should eat a
little bit healthier i know it's it and
so it's gotta
somehow you gotta have a politician or a
group of politicians that
that get it you and i have to run for
office i mean that's the only way this
is gonna work
how's your your mom rubbing off on you
in terms of like the
the the yoga and the spirituality and
the the diet
like what's that look like foreign i
went crazy with the yoga but it had to
be hot yoga as you can imagine i had to
be sweating
i couldn't be like sitting still and
like chanting
so i went nuts with the hot yoga
probably did a thousand
classes or something love it i haven't
done enough of it lately
and um on the spirituality front i don't
know my mom used to say
look no matter what religion you just
got to be a good person
so my thing is just be a good person is
she around still gone
didn't make it um and she died
very young um her mom had cancer as i
said she got cancer her sister got
cancer her cousin got cancer
we lived in that neighborhood i
described yeah uh within a 15-mile
radius there was a big garbage dump
and massive incidents of cancer around
that garbage wow
wow so um a diet um she preached
more plant-based uh she introduced me to
a guy named fred
bishi i don't know yeah yeah he's john
joseph's boy
i don't know my buddy john joseph new
york city hardcore iron man
vegan punk rocker dude but he he's all
about bishi he talks about bishi
all the time guy's like is he still
alive yeah he's still alive he was at my
wedding 92 94 or something 93 probably
he's
um he's a good friend he was texting me
today
and uh so i subscribe more to
plant-based but that doesn't mean a
little bit of animal protein doesn't
slip in
to my diet it shouldn't but um but it
does but i'm i'm
mostly i'm probably 75 80
plant-based um and i should be more
and i fight with everybody over it
including my own kids right it's
interesting because
spartan which is sort of a you know kind
of
a cousin of like the crossfit movement
there's a there's a cross pollination
it feels like a raw meat it's very like
yeah it's very kind of
intertwined with the paleo community
that's now pivoting towards this weird
carnivore diet thing that
is confusing but that's kind of the the
sensibility of a lot of the people that
are participating in your races
and it's interesting that you're coming
from a different place yeah i mean
bishop
first of all i tested it on myself i did
very long distance races
like crazy races um the iditarod by foot
right right and i would carry like
carrots
and olive oil with me and all kinds of
stuff that like doesn't they don't make
any sense but i perform
best on that and so um
i'm just not a believer that said maybe
based on where you come from on the
planet maybe
uh some people need need a little more
meat than others i don't i don't know
but
but bishi's thing is you want to outlive
your competition
and if and if and if you subscribe to
that
i promise you plant-based is the way to
go yeah bishi was like was like a weight
lifter or something
the weight was younger it was weight
lifting and he said um
he said he was going to try a different
way he's 55 years in right now
on raw fruits and veggies wow 55 years
roasting your fruits and veggies
yeah what are the the big obstacles that
you
face for yourself now like what are the
things that you struggle with
dealing with and overcoming well my
biggest obstacle is i got 20 years of my
life invested in
in this thing um i levered up right
before covent and bought my competitor a
tough mudder
uh and um my whole life is upside down
right yeah financially so how are you
how are you maintaining your sanity is
there's so much you can't
you can't control right netflix and
twinkies man
right what are you doing in l.a i came
out to la i have a thing uh
tonight this is a funny story actually
um
anne ran and atlas shrugged you know the
book at the shrugged your fountainhead
uh
i get asked on podcasts like this like
what's one of your favorite books i'm
like atlas shrugged
so i guess there's an ann ran society
that reached out to me and said oh
i know that your favorite book is outlet
shrug so can you come to this thing so
uh laird hamilton gabby reese um maybe
peter thielson people will be there
tonight and they said
i promised pre-cove and i would be at it
so i got a good nice thing
that'll be an interesting it's crowded
it's gonna it's gonna be interesting
yeah
how does you know how you look at the
world and
and and you know think about
people and potential affect the kind of
people that you
hire for your business like when you're
looking to bring somebody on
uh into your organization like what are
the qualities that stand out to you
you know in the early days because i
just didn't have enough
funding to do what we were trying to do
with size and scale
it would be if they had a heartbeat um
they were good enough to work for us
right because we were i was paying like
000 a month um for the first 100 people
to make this thing work we
the expenses were just insane i would
say now
if we really narrowed it down a much
more professional approach it's um you
got to be really enthusiastic
person you got to be like relentless i
don't even care if you have domain
expertise or not because you can learn
that
but if you're just relentless and 24 7
and just like not going to accept
no um and you're honest you've got
integrity that that's good enough for me
yeah
the specific skill set can be trained i
don't care about it but it's more about
that it's more about the disposition
yeah i just i just um i want you know
that uh what is it pareto's principle
right 20
of the people do 80 of the work i just
want more of the
those i just want more of those 20s yeah
yeah yeah
so uh we'll wrap this up
with some thoughts for the person that
feels stuck who's inspired by
what you just shared and is looking for
you know
that that little dose of inspiration to
just start to get out of that
cycle of analysis paralysis that
you know keeps you on the couch
scrolling for the best pair of running
shoes
you've got to sign up for something it
doesn't it could be learning a new one
what about when we can't we can't sign
up
for anything right now uh it could
signing up for something could be as
simple as saying to your friend
and then screaming it from the rooftop
so you're committed you're on the hook
uh we are gonna walk six miles on
saturday
i mean that could be the thing you sign
up it's just gotta be so it could be
we're gonna learn a new language
uh by this date right it's gotta be this
is what we're gonna do
and by this date we're gonna be held
accountable um
and then i would say you know we have a
prayer at spartan
we have our brand has a prayer and we
stole it from a a world war ii
french paratrooper who they found in the
field dead
they pulled the prayer out of his pocket
and basically
he was saying look god everybody is
asking you for the good stuff right they
want to get back with their spouse they
want to get home
a warm shower meal you probably don't
have any of that left
so i'll just ask you for the tough stuff
like the
turmoil the toil uh suffering
and just promise me you'll keep it
coming and you give me the strength to
deal with it so like
if you can turn your thinking around to
more like that like like i might you and
i i might text you and say hey rich i
hope you have a shitty day
uh-huh and that's like yeah i don't it's
a worthwhile day i gotta fight through
today right we don't want we don't want
a complacent easy day
and so if you can change your mindset to
like embracing
tough stuff and committing to it
you just have a better life and what do
you think is the main obstacle that gets
in people's way
well i think i think subconsciously our
legacy hardware and software
is avoiding discomfort like it kept us
from falling off cliffs and freezing out
in the snow and
drowning and and the sooner you
recognize that that's just like old
hardware
that you don't need because you're not
going to get attacked by a lion when you
go outside or drown in the rain
um you got to do this stuff just look i
have a friend who runs the largest hedge
fund in the world
he doesn't need to do anything okay he's
fine
and he his theory was no pain no pain
instead of no pain no gain
no pain nope why would i want any pain
and lately's come around to my way of
thinking
which is and your way of thinking which
is um you know what
uh look he came to japan when i was
living in japan
and they had all these five-star hotels
everything all lined up to do and you
know what i did i took him and his
family
to the the waterfall monks and and it
was freezing it was winter time
and there was ice on the mountain the
waterfall is coming down and we gotta
go down to nothing take all our clothes
off get down to basically nothing and
get under that waterfall and hold these
metal chains
while the japanese in their language are
pulling the demons out of us
and he said that was the best part of
the whole trip yeah right yeah he's not
gonna forget that
that was the best part of the whole trip
it wasn't the fancy hotels the fans
like that suffering was awesome so just
do it
way to stick the landing
powerful joe to senna thank you my
friend uh it's great to see you you're
awesome yeah that was very cool
yeah um appreciate it if you're digging
on joe uh pick up his book spartan up
spartan fit the spartan way
got the spartan up podcast we didn't
even talk about the spartan x
leadership stuff that yeah leadership
stuff we've got all kinds of stuff shoot
me an email at joey spartan.com and and
if you come to the farm
just don't quit it would suck i mean it
would really ruin rich's reputation if
you
came to the farm based on this talk with
rich
and you were one of those ones that quit
right away yeah that might be me i might
show up
you're gonna you're just gonna push me
too hard and i'm gonna be out of here
and the
my whole ship's gonna sink hopefully not
all right thanks man thank you
[Music]
you